ce film we gabrielle roy continue de
fasciner plusieurs années après son
décès en 1983 sa vie et celle de ses
proches ont récemment inspiré des
créateurs au canada donc c'est
véritablement une personnalité marquante
que je te propose de découvrir à travers
une introduction de sa jeunesse et
certaines de ses oeuvres alors gabrielle
roy c'est parti dans 3 2 gabrielle roy
est né à saint boniface au manitoba en
gabrielle roy passe sa jeunesse une
partie de sa vie adulte dans cette
maison située au 375 rue des chambres ou
un lieu aujourd'hui transformée en musée
consacré à l'écrivain gabriel roy était
la benjamine
il y avait vraiment un grand écart entre
elles et les nids donc elle était
presque comme une enfant unique il était
souvent en train de rêvasser et de se
réfugier dans le grenier qui était
probablement un lieu où elles pouvaient
laisser courir son imagination et
culinaires la jeunesse l'enfance ce sont
des éléments primordial dans l'oeuvre de
gabrielle roy
sans oublier un personnage central sa
mère sa façon de raconter
elle raconte probablement n'ayant à plus
de sa mère qui fera mère aimait raconter
ou ici gabriel se rappelle de sa mère
mais li na qui prenait plaisir à
raconter le grand voyage qu'elle avait
refait adolescente avec cette année pour
quitter le québec et venir s'installer
au manitoba
elle avait découvert dans ce voyage
travers la plaine ce qu'elle a conservée
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie et qu'elle m'a
fait partager j'étais trop mais ça
devait être la magie la fascination de
fois
c'était vraiment une façon pour la mère
de la fille de se créer un petit cocon
espoirs privilégie où elle laissait
libre cours à leur imagination alors que
le père lui les textes souvent a surtout
vers la fin de sa vie comme une bulle et
par différents soucis financiers il
avait subi un grand malheur parce que
j'en avais été agent colonisateur il
avait emmené les différents groupes de
colons venus dans les prairies de
l'ouest canadien mais il n'avait perdu
ce poste il appuie pas le bon parti qui
est que pouvoir et donc il se trouve
toujours au lendemain sans emploi et il
sera obligé de trouver d'autres moyens
pour subvenir aux besoins de la famille
et de ce fait la mer aussi commencé à
faire des petites besoins et surtout
l'album même accepté de prendre des
pensionnaires donc gabriel côtoient des
pensionnaires elle entend aussi les
histoires que lui raconte son père à
propos des immigrants qui leur rencontre
et on pourrait penser que ça lui donne
une certaine ouverture à l'autre à la
différence en un sens il n'ya jamais
jeter variétés pour tous ces peuples
ça fait partie de notre vie quotidienne
et gabriel est elle même une minorité en
tant que francophone elle va grandir
dans un contexte où le manitoba a
interdit le français est tout autre la
rentrée langues
dans les écoles de la province gabrielle
roy a dû étudier
lorsqu'on a imposé la langue anglaise
comme la seule langue d'enseignement
1916 elle fréquentait l'académie saint
joseph et grâce aux religieuses qui
assurèrent quand même un peu à
l'enseignement français guerrière loi a
pu maintenir son français est elle à
bien maîtriser l'anglais
après ses études à l'académie st joseph
gabriel va obtenir un brevet
d'institutrice à l'école normale de
winnipeg pour gagner sa vie elle va
choisir l'une des seules voies
accessibles aux femmes à l'époque
l'enseignement mais c'est qu'elle va
exercer à saint boniface et dans
quelques villages au manitoba
je trouve la profession at il même
encore aujourd'hui il m'arrive de
monique pas mes élèves et enseignants
leçon géographie c'est si merveilleux de
capter l'intérêt du genre
et lorsqu'elle n'est pas en train
d'enseigner gabriel s'adonnent au t1 et
à l'écriture
elle se donne pour objectif de devenir
comédienne et quitte le manitoba pour
l'europe en 1937
qu'est ce que cherche moi mais je ne
donnerai le prétexte que j'irai étudié
l'art dramatique
vous pensez peut-être quelques talents
au fond c'est que je désirais surtout
écrire mais j'avais un peu peur le
parcours de cette femme qui partit avec
découvrir
qu'est ce qu'il attendait de sa vie avec
presque rien en poche elle nous donne
tellement permission et de l'os
encourage le séjour de gabriel en europe
a duré près de 12 ans et c'est là
qu'elle va décider de mettre de côté une
carrière au théâtre on lui a signalé
qu'elle n'avait vraiment pas la voix
elle n'avait pas la voie qui portait
assez loin même si elle avait l'ambition
et le désir de faire du théâtre elle
n'avait pas comment ce qui fallait pour
réussir si gabriel n'avait peut-être pas
ce qu'il fallait pour réussir au théâtre
elle décide de tenter sa chance dans le
domaine de l'écriture
certains ces articles sont publiés en
france ce qui lui donne un grand courage
pour vivre de sa plume
de retour au pays en 1939 elle
s'installer à montréal pour collaborer
comme journaliste ou jour et au bulletin
des agriculteurs
c'est au cours de cette période qu'elle
découvrit le quartier saint henri
la vie et la misère des gens pour son
indignation devant tant de misère
inspirèrent son célèbre bonheur
d'occasion publié en 1945 dans bonheur
d'occasion gabriel concentre l'histoire
autour de la misère d'une famille
canadienne française au début de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
l'écrivaine permet de sortir des romans
du terroir et de faire découvrir un
roman urbain où l'action se passe à
montréal
c'est quelque chose qui est inscrit l'un
ville de montréal dans la scène
littéraire partout partout dans le monde
notamment en france
et parlant de la france gabriel devient
la première canadienne à obtenir un
prestigieux prix littéraire français
le prix femina et la traduction anglaise
de son roman de tim floute va être
choisi comme livre du mois par le public
orrespondant le littorail guild of
america
la gloire cabrio être assurée puisque ça
voulait dire que le texte était lui non
seulement français mais en anglais yab
rien vous présenter quelque chose
d'assez différent pour son deuxième
roman
elles vont s'inspirer de son expérience
d'enseignante dans une région reculée du
manitoba la petite poule d'eau les gens
s'attendaient et ce soit une autre
oeuvre dans le genre de bonheur
d'occasion et qu'est ce qu'elle fait
elle nous amène au manitoba et elle ne
parle justement de cours d'eau elle
raconte l'histoire de la famille
tousignant et l'aspiration des bas rhin
à l'égard de l'éducation française de
leurs enfants est donc le troisième
roman alexandre on retrouve le thème de
la nuit en fête
alexandre chênevert frw ticket psy qui
ne semble pas avoir d'avenir devant lui
encore une fois on reconnaît le grand
talent de gabrielle roy qui réussit à
changer dans son quatrième roman rue
deschambault
la plupart de l'intrigué se passe dans
sa maison d'enfance et est le personnage
principal est un peu son alter ego
fictif
la protagoniste de ses dix-huit
nouvelles chapelles christine elle tire
sur ses souvenirs d'enfance
on doit beaucoup d'échos de la famille
de perdriel et on est tenté de confondre
plus fine et gabriel dans ses oeuvres
gabriel un profond intérêt à traiter de
la diversité et de l'altérité que ce
soit la condition de certains n8 partagé
entre la tradition et le progrès moderne
où la situation de certaines familles
immigrantes dans l'ouest canadien
la place de feu aux immigrants lançant
dans ses récits je suis très à leur
gardien jeter et sajoo que l'a priori
nous sommes à une acceptation une espèce
de l'embrasser communauté là avec
beaucoup d'ouverture de façon
inconsciente elle transmet justement ses
propres sentiments vis-à-vis de son
peuple statut de minoritaire
quand il était en france avec le fait
par française québécoise
et même quand elle était au manitoba et
c'est vrai que je n'étais pas anglophone
quand donc et je pris conscience pour la
première fois que j'étais dans mon pays
d'une espèce destiné à être traité en
inférieur c'est avec cette question que
gabriel entame la détresse et
l'enchantement où elle entreprend de
raconter sa vie est comme l'expliquent
le grand spécialiste de gabriel et
biographe françois ricard l'oeuvre
devait compter quatre parties mais
gabriel le temps de rédiger que les deux
premières et le début de la troisième
donc encore aujourd'hui il ya une
certaine part de mystère qui entoure au
gabrielle roy cette personnalité souvent
décrit comme solitaire nostalgiques de
l'ouest canadien qui a fui la vie
publique pour se consacrer pleinement à
la poursuite de son oeuvre il faut pas
oublier je pense ces femmes qui elles se
sont voués à la littérature à une époque
où nous y avait aucune espèce de
permission dans ce sens là aucune espèce
de pétition dans ce sens est qui et qui
ont forgé leur place
cette femme est vraiment une femme très
moderne et qu'on peut venir même s'il
est plus que centenaire
gabriel est une femme indépendante très
avant gardiste pour son ebook est très
déterminé je dirais même que
c'est une psychologue masse passant au
rouge suivie d une formation elle savait
vraiment cerner avec des mots tout une
ambiance une atmosphère
je me demande parfois si si ce que tout
ce que nous connaissons pleurer nous ne
le connaissons en famille et les
relations humaines vie certains s en
effet faire mais les unes est clair
peut-être vous télé at il dit il est né
des clercs peut-être nous éclaire sur
nos relations humaines